Who doesn't love a twist ending?
There's just something about having your expectations
set up and then smashed to smithereens that
makes every movie-goer fall in love with cinema
all over again.
Luckily, plenty of movies boast enough twists
and turns to make our heads spin — and these
are just a handful of the films that have
done it best.
For those out of the loop, Fight Club follows
Ed Norton's unnamed protagonist, an insomniac
working a job he hates to buy things he doesn't
need.
"With insomnia, nothing's real.
Everything's far away.
Everything's a copy of a copy."
After his apartment is blown to pieces in
an explosion, he moves into a rundown house
with Brad Pitt's Tyler Durden, his opposite
in every way ⁠— cool, focused, and ready
to tear the world down.
But what begins as an unlikely friendship
gradually escalates into a bitter rivalry
and, eventually, a pretty heated butting of
heads.
To make a long story short, the two start
a fight club to help men express themselves
and relieve their stress… but it quickly
morphs into a full-blown anti-capitalist terrorist
cell.
By the time Norton's character realizes that
he and Durden are the same person, it's too
late to stop the plan they've put in place.
The movie ends with the destruction of the
city's financial district, wiping out everyone's
debt.
In case you slept through 2017, here's the
gist of Jordan Peele's super-popular, ultra-profitable
Get Out: When Chris, a young black man, meets
the parents of his white girlfriend Rose for
the first time, we soon come to realize that
something isn't quite right with her family.
After Chris meets a peculiar black guest at
the family's garden party …
"GET OUT!"
"Yo."
"Yo, chill, man!"
… viewers are led to believe that the protagonist
is about to be brainwashed into some kind
of modern-day slavery, but the final reveal
is even more mind-blowing: It turns out Chris
is in the clutches of the Order of Coagula,
a cult that transplants the brains of old,
rich white people into the bodies of young
black people.
"I want… your eye, man.
I want those things you see through."
Unlike those that came before him, Chris manages
to escape this awful fate, stuffing his ears
with cotton to avoid being hypnotized.
He fights his way outside and is ultimately
rescued by his best friend Rod.
This wasn't the original ending, however — Peele
also shot a version in which the cops show
up instead of Rod and an innocent Chris is
jailed for killing his kidnappers.
South Korean director Park Chan-wook made
inroads in Hollywood in 2013 after helming
two English-language films, the psychological
drama Stoker and the Chris Evans-led sci-fi
thriller Snowpiercer.
While both drew praise from critics — with
the latter boasting an impressive 95 percent
Certified Fresh rating on Rotten Tomatoes
— most reviewers agreed that Park's best
work was done domestically, and the jewel
in his Korean filmography is undoubtedly Oldboy.
The film follows a drunk named Oh Dae-su who's
framed for the murder of his wife and imprisoned
in an iron-doored hotel room by an unknown
man.
When he's randomly released 15 years later,
he aims to track down his captor with the
help of a young female sushi chef who takes
him in after his ordeal.
The woman and Oh Dae-su fall for each other
and begin a sexual relationship, though unbeknownst
to the pair this is all part of the captor's
grand plan.
Oh Dae-su and the young woman are actually
father and daughter, which Oh's tormentor
takes great pleasure in revealing.
The final installment of a trilogy M. Night
Shyamalan began with 2000's Unbreakable, Glass
reunites Bruce Willis and Samuel L. Jackson's
characters, David Dunn — a.k.a the Overseer
— and Elijah Price, better known as "Mr.
Glass."
Both are banged up in a psychiatric ward alongside
James McAvoy's Kevin Wendell Crumb — a.k.a
the Horde from 2016's Split — a man suffering
from an extreme case of dissociative identity
disorder.
All three are under the care of Dr. Ellie
Staple, a psychiatrist who specializes in
patients who have become convinced that they
have superhuman abilities.
Staple spends the majority of the film attempting
to convince the men that they're delusional,
and she's pretty convincing.
At times, against our better judgment, we
believe her.
"You've convinced yourselves you have extraordinary
gifts, like something out of a comic book.
I am here to discuss the possibility that
you are mistaken."
Of course, she's wrong.
It transpires that Staple is part of a secret
society that has been actively repressing
super-powered people for years.
Price is killed by the Beast, and Staple's
men murder Dunn and Crumb.
There's one final twist, however — Price
hacked the institution's security cameras.
Footage of Dunn and Crumb's super-powered
showdown is leaked to the public, revealing
the existence of superhumans to the world.
A film containing one of the creepiest shock
twists in recent years, Orphan follows a couple
played by Vera Farmiga and Peter Sarsgaard
as they try to move on with their lives after
the death of their unborn child.
In an attempt to save their marriage, the
pair decide to go ahead with their plans for
a third child, adopting a quiet 9-year-old
Russian girl named Esther.
At least, they're lead to believe she's nine.
"I don't think mommy likes me very much."
"Hey, that's not true — mommy loves you."
"It’s alright, it must be hard to love an
adopted child as much as your own."
In truth, Esther is a 33-year-old woman named
Leena Klammer, a psychopath with a growth
disorder who's spent the majority of her life
posing as a pigtailed child and being repeatedly
adopted.
Why does she need to keep finding new families?
She keeps trying to get it on with the dads.
We watch in sheer horror as Esther sets about
seducing her new father and proceeds to kill
him when he isn't receptive.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.